The Joe Rogan experience when by oxen came along,
boxing was my first love, you know, I,
I got distracted by the music game because of, I mean,
by boxing because of the music game, I always wanted to be a boxer,
but it wasn't any gyms and Phil fraud, you know,
so I always said to myself, if I ever make it,
I want to build a boxing gym, a recreation center in my hood,
and that's what I'd done.
And shortly after I'd done that had the opportunity to go in the gym
and I started watching the amateurs and I just kind of fell in love with boxing
all over again. And which ultimately led me.
I pray for a champion, everything I tried to accomplish in life,
always exercise, prayer. It worked for me. So I prayed for a champion.
And, um,
I set up a meeting with Mike Tyson in Las Vegas, and I went to Las Vegas.
This had to be 99 or 2000. So,
you know, I knew a friend that knew Mike and Mike, you know,
accepted the invitation because he was familiar with my movement where rap,
Ralph alive was concerned. And I flew out there, uh,
with my focus on Mike and man, I walked into him spawn, and I was like,
you know, I was on cloud nine. Cause I had never saw him, you know,
in person spoil. And it was always at a fight.
And I walked in and he would throw in leather with another heavyweight.
And I was like starstruck.
And in the midst of watching this Sporn, uh,
Floyd Mayweather came in a gym and flawed, you know, I didn't know who he was.
He kept coming to him and yo Jay, yo, Jay, uh, man, I know, I know,
I know about your group, you know, he's calling groups out and I'm like, Oh,
okay. Thanks bro. Thanks bro. I'm zeroing back in on Mike. Boom, boom,
boom flaw. Come over again. It was just, Hey yo, Jay, yo, man.
I know about this group here, man. And in Jay,
if you want to do something later on, you know, this is my number,
I'll come pick you up. I'm like, all right, bro. Okay. Focus on Mike.
I don't know who Florida is. Right? So afterwards, you know,
me and Mike go to his house to have the meeting that I came to have because my
objective was to become his manager, to be on his management team.
And he and I met for an while.
He got his ex wife on the phone and you know,
I was pretty much convinced I was on the team after the meeting and everything
took place and uh, you know, hung with him all night. The next day,
uh, I tried to reach Mike and I couldn't reach Mike and I was left, uh,
Florida nom. And I asked my friend, I said, who, who number is,
is this number right here? He said, Oh, that's flora Mayweather.
The 130 pound champion. So bam,
a red light went off in my head because pray for a champion long story short me
and was in business together less than a week. That's how his manager,
you didn't even know who he was. I didn't know no idea.
It was when he was pretty boy Floyd. Yeah. That was before money Mayweather.
Is that yeah, he had a totally different style back then too.
He was much more aggressive. Went for the knockout war.
Yeah. Well I think he used his legs a lot more then,
but if he saw the opportunity, he definitely went in for the kill. But you know,
his whole image was different before I came about.
Well, he had a lot of hand problems, right? Like he's had several hand breaks.
Yeah. Well, I don't know about a break, but I know, uh,
we eventually had to get a specialist to wrap his hands because you
know, he would hurt him a lot. Yeah.
Yeah. And do you think that affected his style? Is that like,
cause he developed a very defensive style as he got older.
Um, I think that's a part of a confidence. I think that's a part of, uh,
evolve. And as a fighter, you know, in the beginning,
I think Florida uses legs much more,
but as he evolved with experience, he got comfortable, you know,
with B roll and defense. Yeah. Greatest defense of all time. Oh man.
Yeah. I agree.
I had my friend Andrew Schultz on here yesterday. We were talking about it.
We were like, he might've got hit hard four times in his career,
which is insane. 50 and Oh, and got tagged four times,
which is unthinkable. No.
He was amazing. But his work ethic is amazing. You know, the guy I got to work,
you know, I've had an opportunity to like witness a lot of fighters, work ethic,
Andre Ward's and Florida.
Maywell the work ethic is unlike any fight I ever saw.
Yeah. You don't get there without it. Exactly.
Because there's so many talented people to so many athletic people.
There's so many fierce dudes, but to be a champion. Yeah.
You need everything. You need gifts. You need athletic gifts.
You need a sharp mind. You need a,
a passion for the technical aspects of the game, but you gotta have that ethic.
If you don't have that work ethic, you don't, you never keep it going. You, you,
you always fall short of your expectations and without naming any names,
we all know those champions that could have been great,
but they got fat in between camps and they just never trained as
hard as they should've. And yeah, I mean,
some of the all-time great suffered from it. Like Roberto Duran,
after he beat sugar, Ray, Leonard, and sugar,
I knew it capitalized on it and forced a quick rematch when he knew that
Duran was fat. Duran is partying and drinking and yeah,
a guy like Floyd Mayweather never did that. Nah, never got out of shape.
Man. He would, you know,
Florida was a type of fighter that would party with everybody, but no drinking,
no smoking. You sit back and watch and observe the whole movement.
I remember watching a video of him leaving a club in Vegas.
It showed him at the club hanging out with everybody,
leaving the club at two in the morning running.
Oh yeah. We used to do that all the time. Yeah. Regular pants on.
We would watch fights together. And right after the fight, he was ready to run.
Yo Jay, yo,
ain't nobody gonna kiss me slipping on the way they can beat you as catch you
out of shape. They ain't gonna catch me slipping,
take off running down the strip.
It's amazing.
And having his brother or having his uncle Roger and
having his father, you know,
two world-class fighters and having grown up,
seeing these guys,
seeing his uncle when Roger Mayweather was a champion,
he had a vicious style.
He was his right hand was a thing of beauty. I mean, people forgot.
Like I was watching some Roger Mayweather fights the other day.
And to have his father, a guy who gave sugar, Ray Leonard,
a hell of a fight yet there's so much talent,
so much knowledge and understanding of boxing in that family to grow up with
that.
And to have that mindset like Floyd has always observing and watching everything
that dude just absorbed everything.
Well. Yeah. And not only watching, he had to spar with Roger.
So you talking about, you know,
having to learn how to protect yourself against the best as a kid.
So, you know, he had access to a lot of power and evidently, you know,
there's no doubt about it. It benefited him in a major way.
When you met Floyd, who was the 130 pound champion.
And did you just immediately started working with him?
Um, yeah, but it was a process and it was, um,
it wasn't easy because I came into a situation where his
father and his uncle was his manager and I wasn't embraced,
uh, you know, with, with love, you know,
because they kind of felt like I was imposing on
a situation.
He had a $12 million contract on the table at the time I came in that
everybody wanted him to sign and a flaw called a contract,
a slave contract before I came, but they blame me,
but him calling him the contract, a slave contract. So.
The provisions in the contract that he didn't like.
Well, he, he just thought 12 million wasn't enough. You know what I mean?
And uh, you know, ultimately I had to, uh,
go in and do some damage control.
And one of the things that I told him when, you know, when I met him, I said,
if I can't make this better,
I don't want to eat off of your 12 million that already been offered to you.
So I had an opportunity to have a meeting with said, Abraham, you know,
at the time was the, uh, the president of, uh, HBO.
And I pretty much just asked the guy, you know,
how could we get around this $12 million contract?
How can I, uh, make this a bigger contract?
And at the time he told me about the fighter named Diego Corellis.
He was like, you know, if you all would be willing to fight Diego Corollas,
then this could jump up to 35 million or so if y'all was able to beat Diego
Corrales. And, um, you know, that was interesting to me. You know,
I went home and done some due diligence on Diego Corvallis at the time.
And at that particular time, Diego had, uh,
jumped on his ex wife and kind of beat up.
He had charges, you know, uh, kind of done her pretty bad,
but bad to the extent where he was facing jail time. And,
and I saw that and I went back to Florida. I say, flawed. I said,
it's a perfect time to fight da go corral. As I said, I even have a,
a marketing tool.
We can whip him for every battle woman in the United States of America.
So he heard me out, but he wasn't embracing it. No, no, no, no, no, no,
no. Jay, anytime to do that right now. No, no, no, no.
So he didn't want to fight Diego because Diego skillset, well, you know,
I don't want to say flaw was scared, but at the time, you know,
everybody thought Diego could beat Florida.
He was like 30 and over 29 knockouts jail was a wild man. Yeah. Diego was,
he was a knockout artist and he just felt like it wasn't the time I
talked to him for like four hours and couldn't convince him.
So I decided to go home and I went home about six in the morning
and I woke up about 11 in the morning with a message from him. Yo,
yo Jay a to you, you know, as my manager and uh, you think I should fight him.
I fight him. So it was Dan where, you know, I was celebrating, come like,
Whoa, we finna get Diego.
So I called the people at HBO and they told me they didn't
have a date. They wouldn't have a date to a next year or something like that.
And it was then I decided to use, uh,
some of my record label, uh, talent. You know,
I had to build my record company without having video without having
radio, you know, just pulling publicity stunts.
So I told Florida, I say, here's what we're gonna do. Uh,
Lennox Lewis and David tool was fighting at the, at the Mandalay Bay.
I say during the press conference, um, here in Diego's post cognitive fight,
I say, during the press conference, we're going to surround Diego.
My head of home is the surround Diego.
And I want you to come and just push him and, and we're going to stop the fight,
right? We just, ain't going to end. Ain't gonna be no free fight,
but you go and get your push in on him. We're going to stop it.
We're going to steal the show. That was my objective. And, um,
that came to fruition. You know,
we went and stole the show at the press conference. That was night, Sunday.
We was on the front page of the, uh, Las Vegas time. And you know,
Monday or Tuesday I'll call them and they say, Oh, we got a date for you.
Uh, I love that you telling me this because I always wonder,
I always wonder when I see those kinds of altercations,
how many of those are coordinated by a wise man who understands
publicity? Quite a few. Wouldn't you?
Why wouldn't you, you know,
it's marketing catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free.
Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.